to Turkey now where this music video has
caused quite a stir the 15-minute track
features no less than 20 rappers and his
title
sasame Turkish for I can't stay silent
and it's quickly shaping up to become
the battle cry of the otherwise
increasingly silent opposition to
president a red ship type Edwyn and for
more on the story I'm joined now by DWS
reporter Nicole Elise welcome and Nicole
as we said this video has caused quite a
stir in Turkey tell us why and what
makes it such a hit an explosive hit in
air jo-ann's Turkey it's indeed an
explosive hit you want to phrase it like
that because it addresses issues that
haven't been talked about in public in
Turkey for quite some time we're talking
about violence against women political
corruption but also the destruction of
the planet and the reason why these
issues have been kind of in kept under
the table for some time might be that in
July 2016 when president edwin was
almost Elstad - by a coup attempt tens
of thousands of people in the public
sector such as teachers but also doctors
lost their jobs in what human rights
activists labeled as a sort of
witch-hunt against people who might have
a different opinion of the president so
there were also lots of journalists that
have been detained once and again and
again and that pretty much wiped out the
public square and left social media as
one of the sources that people could go
to to talk about issues and these
rappers have pretty much taken this soap
box and turned it into a ghetto blaster
let's just have a quick listen for
digital console aku sharing videos
[Music]
because they should be level on us
so you see they're really not moving
back they're really sticking to that
title so some um I can't stay silent
okay now I'm sure everyone is not amused
by this video at all but what about the
other ordinary it Turks how are they
finding it well it has received over 21
million clicks in just a week which is a
really lot it really has hit a nerve
there and so many clicks in a week it's
really a tremendous and an observer of
Turkish politics whose name is can a car
is calling this song a political
earthquake and quote incendiary art the
kind that holds a mirror up to society
and then shatters it and it's also
prompted many to go to social media and
to talk about this video and exchange
their opinions on that video and as you
might expect there has also been some
blowback by anchors for mamaia for
example who's also a member of Aaron's
party he's claiming in a tweet that the
video is trying to instigate rebellion
so you see the discussion is really
ongoing and as you said before it's
causing quite a stir up here okay and
what about the rappers themselves how
are they kind of responding to this
fallout from their video DW has got
exclusive access to some of them so we
talk to them and they say well they
don't want people to pick sides there
pretty much want to encourage people to
speak up to start a conversation about
these also global issues and then maybe
try to find solutions to these issues so
pull together and also see what can be a
brighter future for Turkey let's just
quickly listen to what they're saying so
the second example we do malnutrition
meal and master at the Museo Soumaya at
our second demolition condemned easy
switch publicity image audio most get
active shooter response from all other
court mirrors
punjah problem in tamil in the atashi
this is a cork we do this in our
diplomas olden days I between Yoda 80
senators or is done in between
misogynist and against Linda choke
Falcon de Luna and Artemis survey or
item dish engineering Quran me me say no
this wholesome be our the Hawks of the
garden they boo no delay get your
mistake card or myself so you see
they're really trying to pick up maybe
long overdue discussion year and
certainly reclaiming the public square
and the song Sousa mom could very well
be the beginning of a new movement that
we are observing in Turkey and targeting
they must see you two seem to be trying
to encourage debate and discussion and
become a catalyst for change Nicole
Reese that was a very interesting story
thank you very much